Welcome back. We're back in the United States in California,
and behind me is the Stanford dish.
Now, the dish is a radio telescope, and it uses its parabolic reflector
to focus radio waves into its antenna.
Now, radio waves are just another form of light.
Light does not travel instantaneously from the stars to our eyes.
It takes time for light to make that journey.
What this means is that when we look deep into space,
we're actually looking back in time.
In this unit, we'll learn a little bit about special relativity
and some of the fascinating but completely unintuitive physics that happen
when we move at speed near the speed of light.